European Union transport ministers have
agreed on a proposal to increase the
availability of alternative fuels across
the EU to help stimulate demand for
clean power the aim is to reduce
Europe's dependence on fossil fuels
improve energy security and cut
greenhouse gas emissions from sources
like Motor Vehicles this would be done
in part by setting a minimum number of
recharge points for electric cars in EU
countries and outlets for natural gas
and hydrogen negotiations on the
proposals are soon to be launched with
the European Parliament it's hoped that
this infrastructure could be in place by
2030 the ministers also took stock of
progress made on improving air passenger
rights the Commission's proposed ways to
clear up gray areas on rules concerning
the rights of people whose flights are
delayed or cancelled and to boost
complaint handling regulations the goal
is to strike a balance between passenger
rights and avoiding high costs for
airlines meanwhile ministers responsible
for telecommunications held a first
policy debate on ways to limit mobile
telephone roaming charges and barriers
to service providers doing business
across the EU The ministers welcomed the
aims of the proposals on updating
Europe's telecommunications regulatory
framework in terms of boosting growth
and creating jobs particularly for young
people but many underlined the need to
maintain stability and predictability
for investors